>> Jesse: EVIL TRUMP STRIKES
AGAIN, SHOCKING IN IMAGES OF
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN SPEAKING IN
CAGES ON THE FLOOR.
NOT SO FAST EVERYONE, TURNS OUT
THESE PICTURES WERE FOUR YEARS
OLD.
THAT WAS WHEN THEIR HERO, OBAMA
WAS IN CHARGE.
AND WITH THAT, THE LOUD
CONDEMNATIONS GO SILENT.
BUT WHO CARES NOW, THEIR IDOL
WAS BOSS AT THE TIME.
THIS PHOTO OF AN ALL BABY SEAT
IMMIGRATION DETENTION BUS WAS
ALSO CALLED A PRISON BUS JUST
FOR BABIES.
BUT THE PHOTO WAS ALSO FROM
OBAMA’S ERA AND IT’S A BUS FOR
FIELD TRIPS.
AND DID YOU HEAR THE WIDELY
SHARED CLAIM ABOUT 1500
IMMIGRANT KIDS THAT WERE
SEPARATED FROM MOM AND DAD AGAIN
BY EVIL TRUMP?
THESE CHILDREN ACTUALLY ARRIVED
ALONE MINUS THEIR PARENTS AND
THEN WERE PLACED AMONG SPONSORS.
THE GOVERNMENT HAD LOST TRACK OF
THEM WHICH SAYS SOMETHING ABOUT
THE SYSTEM, THE SYSTEM THAT
TRUMP WANTS TO FIX.
AND SO AS TRUMP CEMENTS HIS
AGENDA THROUGH SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATION, THESE FOLKS HAVE
THE VAPORS OVER IMAGINARY
DISCRIMINATION.
BUT IF YOU CAN’T BLAME HIM FOR
THAT, WHAT’S NEXT?
THE MEDIA CAN’T EVEN CHECK THE
DATE ON THE PHOTO AND THAT’S
THEIR JOB TO CHECK FACTS.
ALL THE USUAL SUSPECTS, IDENTITY
ADVOCATES, AND IT’S NO LONGER A
CATCHPHRASE, IT’S A BRAND.
I HAVE AN IDEA.
DANA, WHERE IS IT?
I LOST IT.
HERE IT IS.
TRUMP SHOULD GO ON NATIONAL TV
AND LAYOUT POINT BY POINT HIS
PLAN TO EMBARRASS THE DEMOCRATS
WITH THE FACT THAT HE IS
ACTUALLY OFFERING A PLAN FOR
CITIZENSHIP THAT THEY DON’T.
BUT DON’T DO IT ON TWEETS, GO
OUT AND DO IT.
THAT’S A GOOD IDEA.
>> Dana: I THINK YOU COULD DO
MORE POLICY ORIENTED SPEECHES.
JUST DO THAT AND NOTHING ELSE.
HE COULD DO AN OVAL OFFICE OF
THE ADDRESS WHICH WOULD BE ONE
WAY TO DO IT WHICH REALLY
FOCUSES THE MIND AND MEANS THAT
WOULD BE A PRIMETIME ADDRESS.
IF THIS WAS A NUMBER ONE ISSUE,
CERTAINLY FOR REPUBLICANS BUT
ALSO AN ECONOMIC ISSUE, THEY
HAVE ALL THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE AND A LOT OF HOUSE
REPUBLICANS SIGNING THIS
DISCHARGE POSITION TO ACTUALLY
FORCE VOTES ON THE DACA ISSUE,
SO THE PRESIDENT WOULD BE RIGHT
TO GET OUT IN FRONT OF IT.
IN THE MEANTIME, THE OTHER THING
THAT YOU SHOULD DO IS SAY, I’M
NOT GOING TO WAIT FOR CONGRESS
TO FIX THIS ISSUE.
WHATEVER HE CAN DO TO FIX THE
SYSTEM AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS
WITHIN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
ABOUT KEEPING TRACK OF THESE
CHILDREN, HE COULD LAY THAT OUT,
TOO.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU SAW THIS
OVER THE WEEKEND BECAUSE YOU ON
LIKE ME HAVE A LIFE, BUT
IVANKA TRUMP TWEETED A PHOTO OF
SHE HAD A PICTURE OF HER SON
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
LIKE, WHILE DISMISSING CHILD
NARRATIVE GOING ON.
>> I DIDN’T REALLY LOOK AT AE
BLACKBERRY A LOT, OR iPHONE
THIS WEEKEND.
I TRIED TO UNPLUG.
EVERY TIME I DID DIVE IN AND
CHECK IT OUT, THE MEDIA WAS
SCREWING UP.
EVERY SINGLE TIME, WHETHER IT
WAS IVANKA OR THIS.
AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
STORY ABOUT THE PHOTOS AND HE
HAD A GREAT LINE AND HE SAID,
THE DEMOCRATS KEEP GETTING HIT
SQUARE BETWEEN THE EYES AND THEY
DON’T EVEN REALIZE IT.
THINK ABOUT THIS, YOU HAVE THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION, YOU HAVE
THE KNEELING, OPPOSING THE TAX
CUTS.
EVERYTHING KEEPS BACKFIRING ON
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE SAD THING IS, THIS PHOTO
GOES OUT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
TIMES AND THEN THE RETRACTION
AND THE DELETION DOESN’T GET
SEEN.
THE REASON THEY DO THIS, THE
REASON THEY HAVE THE POLICY TO
SEPARATE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IS TO DISCOURAGE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, TO DISCOURAGE
FAMILIES FROM TAKING KIDS ACROSS
THE TREACHEROUS, HOT, DANGEROUS
SOUTHERN BORDER TRIP, AND THEY
WANT TO DISCOURAGE DANGEROUS AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
SO IF THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
POLICY, LET’S GET A DEAL ON
DACA, A DEAL ON MIRROR
MERIT-BASED.
IF YOU ARE JUST GOING TO DO A
POTSHOT, YOU’RE GOING TO
EMBARRASS THEM.
SO SOME WOULD SAY IT’S A MORE
HUMANE POLICY TO DO THAT.
THAT’S THE ARGUMENT.
AND THAT IS WHERE YOU PLACE THEM
WITH SPONSORS LIKE YOU WOULD
FOSTER CARE.
>> ONE OF THE PROBLEMS HERE
THAT’S BEEN GOING ON FOR TWO
YEARS, THERE’S SO MUCH EMOTIONAL
BAGGAGE, THEIR CONFIRMATION BIAS
FORCES THEM TO SEE EVERYTHING.
IT’S GOT TO BE HIS FAULT, IT’S
GOT TO BE HIS FAULT.
THEY HAVEN’T YET BEEN ABLE TO
SHAKE THAT.
>> I THINK YOU COULD SAY THE
SAME ABOUT BARACK OBAMA OR
HILLARY CLINTON.
BUT NEVER FROM YOU, JESSIE.
BECAUSE I DON’T LISTEN TO
LIMBAUGH.
BUT IT’S INCREDIBLY EMOTIONAL
BECAUSE THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE’S
LIVES AND AS JESSE JUST
MENTIONED, THEY ARE VERY
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS.
WHEN YOU HAVE UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR SHOWING UP OF THE BORDER,
IT’S A HEARTBREAKING SITUATION.
BOTH SIDES TOOK ON TO SUCH
EXTREMES NOW THAT THE SPACE FOR
A DEAL IS INCREASING IS
INCORRECT INCREASINGLY
SHRINKING.
IF THE PRESIDENT WENT OUT AND
GAVE AN ADDRESS THAT WAS
SOMEWHERE DOWN THE MIDDLE AND
TRY TO THINK BOTH SIDES
TOGETHER, I DEPENDING ON WHAT IT
SAID WOULD THINK THAT WAS
PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA.
THE CHALLENGE IS, THE REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS ISN’T ON THE SAME PAGE
PARTICULARLY IN THE HOUSE, IN A
MIDTERM HERE.
NOW WE ARE IN THE SITUATION
WHERE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS SEPARATED 800 CHILDREN FROM
THEIR PARENTS SINCE OCTOBER,
OFTEN FOR GOOD REASONS AND
SOMETIMES NOT.
THIS IS HEARTBREAKING, AND NO
ONE IN THIS POLITICAL CLIMATE IT
SEEMS LIKE IT’S ACTUALLY TRYING
TO FIX IT.
>> YOU SHOULD BE A SPONSOR.
I VOLUNTEER YOU.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE EXPOSED AS
WRONG, THEY NEVER ADMIT IT.
THEY JUST REMOVE THEIR TWEETS
AND RUN AWAY.
AND THAT DRIVES ME NUTS.
>> YES.
BUT THAT IS TRUE, YOU SEE THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA MAKING THESE
MISTAKES AND THEY CHASE AFTER
THE ACCOUNTS AND THEY PUT UP
FALSE STORIES.
PHOTOGRAPH SAYS FROM 2,014.
EVERYONE SHOULD CARE, WHATEVER
YOUR POLITICS OR ADMINISTRATION
YOU ARE IN, ABOUT CHILDREN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ACTUAL
FACTS OF THE LAWS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DEMONSTRATIONS FOLLOWING THE LAW
ON THE BOOK IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU
DO WHEN PEOPLE ENTER THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY WITH CHILDREN.
THE GOAL AND AIM BEHIND IT IS TO
BE PROTECTIVE OF CHILDREN SO IT
DOESN’T FOSTER THIS WHOLE LEGAL
OF HUMAN TRACK THEY CAME.
DON’T ENTER THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY AND DON’T PUT YOUR
CHILDREN AT RISK.
OTHER PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING IT
AND TRYING TO GET INTO THE
COUNTRY LEGALLY.
IT IS A NATION OF IMMIGRANTS AND
WE EMBRACE AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO APPLY FOR LEGAL CITIZENSHIP.
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HAVE
SOME 3,000 FAMILIES, SO HOW IS